what's going on everybody it's Warren
and yesterday we got the second official
trailer for Avengers endgame it was
really awesome and we definitely got way
more than I thought we would get but out
of all of the footage that we have the
footage from this trailer from the first
trailer from the Super Bowl TV spot we
have not seen the Hulk in fact we really
haven't even seen Bruce Banner that much
in any of the footage well there's a lot
of rumors going around right now and
there have been theories out there that
have stated that we're going to see
world breaker Hulk in Avengers in game
and that's why they're covering it up
now world breaker Hulk is insanely
powerful
many people say he is the strongest Hulk
by far so in this video I'll talk a
little bit about its backstory and how
we could see him and how it would make
sense for him to appear in Avengers end
game if you're new to my channel I'm
doing a giveaway right now giving away 5
imax tickets so you and some friends can
go see Avengers in game in IMAX if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so sum of
world breaker Hulk story has already
been set up in the MCU
but obviously they're not going to take
the story from the comics and just have
it play out in the movies the Russo
brothers have already said they don't do
that although they do draw inspiration
from the comics so just a quick back
story on world breaker Hulk for those of
you who don't know about him in the
world breaker Hulk story Stephen strange
Tony Stark Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four and Black Bolt all decide
that the Hulk is too dangerous to keep
on earth so they knock him out and they
send him off into space in a spaceship
the original plan was to send him to a
planet that had only plant life and no
other life so he couldn't hurt anybody
however he wakes up mid-flight and he
sees a message from those for who he
thought were his friends and he becomes
enraged and he loses it and this knocks
the ship off course and he winds up on a
planet filled with gladiators well as it
turns out these gladiators were actually
the same strength as the Hulk and could
actually hurt him so Bruce Banner and
the Hulk made a deal they would remain
as the Hulk but keep Bruce banners mind
they both agreed that this was for the
best and they fought through the
gladiatorial ranks until the Hulk was on
top
the hulk ving led a revolution against
the planets leader overthrowing him and
ultimately giving the planet peace and
the hulk found peace as well he even had
a wife who was pregnant with their
unborn baby
but then the ship that brought him to
the planet exploded and it killed his
wife and his unborn baby and millions of
people as well the Hulk is absolutely
infuriated that his friends would rig
the ship that sent him there to explode
killing his wife and millions of people
so he sets out to earth but first he
stops off at the moon and easily defeats
Black Bolt and he sends a message to
earth telling them to evacuate the city
because he's coming for blood Tony Stark
gets his Hulkbuster armor and calls in a
whole slew of different heroes to try
and take on the Hulk ultimately he
defeats them all including Iron Man the
Fantastic Four and even one of the
strongest versions of Doctor Strange he
ends up in prison Amal and makes them
fight to death in an arena but then
sentry shows up and the Hulk and century
fight until they both revert back to
their human forms Bruce has finally
calmed down and is about to call it
quits until somebody in his group called
the warbound stabbed century this person
then revealed that he was the person
that rigged his ship to blow up killing
his wife and unborn child and those
millions of people because the Hulk
taught him to always keep fighting and
this is where the Hulk gets madder than
he has ever been before so mad that
gamma radiation is going through his
eyes and out of his mouth The Hulk slaps
his hands together and the force is so
strong that it shakes the entire earth
he even stops on the ground and with
just one step causes earthquakes along
the entire eastern seaboard The Hulk
then yells out at tony stark telling him
to use his ultimate weapon on him before
he breaks the world a satellite beam
then shoots out from space and it
reverts the Hulk back to banner so
that's a quick recap of who world
breaker Hulk is I recommend you read
that story but like you heard there are
already some things that have played out
from this story in the MCU at the end of
age of Ultron the Hulk himself is the
one who actually decides that he's not
fit for earth and he ultimately ends up
once a car while on Sekar he ends up
fighting through the ranks of the
gladiator arena until he is ultimately
at the top and then of course we all
know about the revolution at the end
the revolution has begun revolution and
then of course it's basically confirmed
that we're going to get Professor Hulk
in Avengers end game which would align
with the Hulk and banner deciding to use
the Hulk's body but use Bruce banners
brain so I definitely think that we're
getting professor Hulk in Avengers in
game no matter what that has basically
been confirmed with official promo art
from marvel that has been released but
Professor Hulk has a limitation in the
comics professor Hulk has a fail-safe
inside of them for if he gets too angry
he will automatically revert back to
Bruce Banner this will not defeat Thanos
the Hulk has already lost a fan of an
infinity war and the Russo brothers the
directors of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame have come out and said
that when Thanos and the Hulk fought
Thanos was not using the power stone so
it was just hand-to-hand combat and
Thanos kicked his butt so if the Hulk
wants to fight against Thanos he's going
to have to get angrier he's going to
have to get madder than he's ever been
before so the question is what is going
to send the Hulk over the edge to make
him become world breaker Hulk and let me
just clarify again they're not going to
take the story from the comics obviously
it's a completely different story and
they won't call him world record huh lil
b a version of the world breaker hulk so
there are a few things that could send
him over the edge and that's what a lot
of people are talking about right now
and the first one is a death or multiple
deaths right now the most talked about
is if natasha romanoff aka black widow
dies we've kind of seen the love between
them grow over the years
specifically in age of ultron and there
was kind of a flashback to that in thor
ragnarok as well and in Avengers
infinity war we had that super not
awkward moment yeah and Black Widow
could possibly be Bruce banners only
hope at love and a possible normal life
so that could send him over the edge but
also multiple deaths could send him over
the edge as well if you have people like
Tony Stark and Steve Rogers dying that
could definitely do it but I think one
of the biggest factors that is going to
come into play for Avengers in game is
the Infinity Gauntlet and the Infinity
stones we know that not just anybody
we'll the power of the Infinity stones
let alone the Infinity Gauntlet so if
they want to use the Infinity Gauntlet
to undo the snap somebody is going to
have to wield it and the Hulk is
probably the perfect candidate more like
famous than anybody especially because
if he gets angrier and angrier he can't
really die but the Infinity Gauntlet is
made out of metal just like Thor's axe
Stormbreaker
and remember what Thor said about the
weapons made from aroo metal you simply
lack the strength to yield it your
bodies would crumble and mines collapse
into madness the Infinity Gauntlet
is a weapon made from aroo metal you
need a certain strength to wield it and
the Hulk may not have that at first it
may send his mind into madness giving us
world breaker Hulk but at the same time
the Avengers are going to need the
strongest possible version of the Hulk
that they can get it may not even take
of the entire Infinity Gauntlet with all
of the stones in it even if the Hulk
holds an infinity stone in his hand that
could be enough to send him over the
edge
it took quill Gamora rocket and Drax all
of them to contain the power of the
Power Stone and quill was part celestial
at the time so some of the Infinity
stones could still be too much for the
Hulk to handle but it's the Hulk he
doesn't die he just gets angrier and
angrier and stronger and stronger and
this might actually be their plan if
they get a hold of an infinity stone
they know that none of them will really
be able to wield it maybe thought maybe
Captain Marvel but they know that the
Hulk can't die you'll have a Hulk that
continues to get stronger and stronger
as he tries to contain the power of the
Infinity stone and then you'll have the
Infinity stone that would be the
strongest version of the Hulk that we
would see in Avengers in game The Hulk
at a strongest level combined with the
power of an infinity stone there's been
a lot of talk about seeing the strongest
possible versions of the original six
Avengers because we know that this is
most likely the last time that we're
going to see all of them together some
of the characters will be retiring so it
would make sense that we would see the
absolute best versions of them in
avengers endgame and this would
definitely be the strongest version of
the Hulk so let me know what you think
about this do you think that we're going
to get a version of world breaker Hulk
in Avengers in game and if so how do you
think it's going to happen let me know
what you think in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the
and stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers in game as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you